hey this is pressure Locker many people
have been confused by this problem on
Facebook and Twitter in this video I'm
going to present two different ways to
arrive at the correct answer one way to
solve this problem is to translate the
numerical equation into a sentence
imagine all the quantities involve money
the equation starts out with 7 which
will translate as meaning that you start
out with $7 the equation then has plus 7
divided by 7 this is interpreted as
receiving a 1/7 chair of $7 a 1/7 chair
of $7 is $1 and you're receiving the
money so you're going to want to add $1
we then have plus 7 times 7 that can be
interpreted as receiving 7 dollars a
total of 7 different times
how much money do you get 7 times 7 is
equal to 49 so that means you receive 49
more dollars finally we have minus 7
which means that seven dollars is taken
away from you we subtract seven dollars
how much money do you end up with at the
end 7 plus 1 is 8 8 plus 49 is 57 minus
7 is 50 you would end up with $50 and
the correct answer to this equation is
50 this problem is also a good reminder
about the order of operations this is a
hierarchy in which operations are
evaluated we have parentheses brackets
exponents orders multiplication division
and then finally addition subtraction
these can be remembered by PEMDAS or
botanist if you have operations of the
same precedence you want to evaluate
them from left to right we don't have
any parentheses or exponents but we do
have a multiplication and a division so
we want to evaluate these before we
evaluate the additions or the
subtractions we have a division of 7
divided by 7 and we have a mole
duplication of seven times seven 7/7
evaluates to 1 and seven times seven
evaluates to 49 we substitute these
results into our equation we have 7 plus
1 plus 49 minus 7 we now only have
addition and subtraction which we can
evaluate from left to right 7 plus 1 is
equal to 8 8 plus 49 is equal to 57 57
minus 7 is equal to 50 and that gets us
our correct result of 50 did you figure
this out thanks for watching this video
please subscribe to my channel I make
videos on math and game theory you can
catch from a blog mind your decisions
which you can follow on Facebook Google+
and patreon you can catch me on social
media at pressure Locker and if you
liked this video please check out my
books there links in the video
description